hi my name is Michael and I'm from
Central City I mean mild it Menifee
California so I was just wondering you
guys have introduced a lot of speedsters
to the show like Jay Garrick Wally West
Jesse quick are you gonna introduce Bart
Allen and how would you do it uh I mean
we haven't uh as of now we're not but
that's you know it's the flash so
anything's possible
all right their ideals hey what's up
guys Spencer my question is kind of a
crossover question between legends and
the flash how critically Wilburys
decisions play a role in legends and
vice versa it's you know it's it's it's
all one universe so they all have
ripples but those guys were traveling
through time you know on their own
mission so they're kind of in their own
timeline - it's really you what we're
showing is it's really affecting arrow
so you'll see it on that side mostly
thanks mmm adorable mm-hmm hi guys I'm
Kylie I'm from San Diego and my question
is like my question was if you weren't
casted as the role you played um what
character would you like to play on the
same show on flash cool
sisqó missus go to places gone III don't
want to be like Harry I think that's a
great hair Jerry so we could still have
those interactions exactly we would just
be flip-flopping yeah you can throw spun
around flop flip yeah
good thanks for having us in San Diego
by the way okay thank you
awesome and this is uh this is gonna be
the last question so okay
sick cow this is it cool Maspero real
innit
I am my name is Chris I'm from Lemoore
California I just wanted to ask how did
it feel to work with Kevin Smith oh he
is amassed yeah the best yeah he's just
most genuine guy yeah that's a
tremendous question to end on because we
I think collectively just think the
world of Kevin Smith I'm sure all you
people who know and why we just yeah
yeah well does hurt applause yeah he's
tremendous if you love working it yeah I
mean we worked with him towards the end
of the season and he it's a long season
and we love our job but you're tired at
the end of the season and the crews
tired and he came in he uplifted
everyone's spirit and it's you kid
that's not a director's job but he did
it and it was impressive I mean like
right before we would do a take you
would say alright best job in the world
yeah let's do it yeah that speaks to
like what a mensch that guy is and what
a mensch and in this universe how much
how he's respected and all he's
accomplished just a quick nugget one of
the greatest moments I've seen on set in
our entire two-plus seasons was when
Kevin saw Grant in the flash suit for
the first time Kevin took three steps
back and teared up teared up and I
needed I started to hyperventilate
across my first time to be in the suit
we did it we took a picture together
like before we even like shot the scene
he like needed a picture with him again
the soon it makes you excited about what
you do yeah you know and okay so last
for you guys for the actors now that the
the flower overs has grown so big down
the line what show would you love to
take your character to for a visit I
think legends would be cool because of
the time travel you get to
we're a bunch of different stuff see
Michael Jackson maybe they'll be cool I
think for iris going to Supergirl over
cat Co Co listen I would never turn down
an opportunity to work with Calista
Flockhart so I was gonna say the same
thing I would really like to reunite on
screen with Calista Flockhart um I've
done them all except for legends so I
want to do legends and I I just I have
the deepest love for Victor Garber I
miss being on set with that man
so mm-hmm Victor Garber yeah man yeah
just sell you on legends well is Walking
Dead Bart oh no no no no what what is it
really
oh that's weird Danielle I want to go to
Supergirl to hang out with those awesome
ladies I mean yeah for curiosity's sake
Supergirl but if we're going outside the
universe and breaking the rules a little
bit
Oh gonna go with Rick and Morty yes
uh yeah I was curious to see what soup
ago would be like all right well maybe
you will all have the chance thank you
guys you were an incredible crowd Inc
you give it up to the flash
you